Breaking means to apply friction, lots of it, and for breaking it's vital to distinguish
between two different regimes of friction--static friction and kinetic friction.
If this object is at rest with respect to that surface, we can apply forces up to a certain threshold force
without setting this object in motion, which remains static.
Experiments showed that this threshold of force is a constant times the rate force,
which often is called N because it's a normal force.
It is perpendicular to the surface. Its coefficient is called the coefficient of static friction µs.
As long as the force that we apply doesn't exceed this force, this object won't be set in motion.
When this force becomes larger than the threshold, the object will be set in motion.
For example, if the mass of this object is 1 kg, the gravitational force would be almost 10 N.
A pretty high value for this coefficient of static friction would be 1,
which means that the threshold force is at 1  10 N.
It would have to exert a force of 10 N or more to set this object in motion.
If we apply less, it remains static.
Typically, this coefficient of static friction ranges between 1/3 and 1, which means that typically
to set an object in motion, we need to apply less force sideways than the force with which
gravity pulls that object down.
Things are easier in the kinetic regime.
We need to apply a certain force to keep this object going at a constant velocity.
So this force is nothing else but the force exerted by friction, and from experiments,
we find that this force is some constant times the normal force,
the force exerted by gravity in this case, and this is the coefficient for kinetic friction.
In the kinetic regime, we got the same expression but it's an equal sign.
In this case it's not a threshold--we compute the force as such.
What's of imminent importance for breaking is that the coefficient of static friction tends to be
larger than the coefficient of kinetic friction.
The coefficient of kinetic friction maybe be 1/4 less than the coefficient of static friction
or it may even be smaller, and now think about breaking.
We want to apply the maximum amount of friction.
The maximum amount of friction is found in this static regime,
because the coefficient of static friction is higher than the coefficient of kinetic friction.
What we need to prevent is the locking of wheels.
When wheel stays locked, it's sliding on the ground, and we're in the regime of kinetic friction.